hey friends have you ever picked up your
guitar to find noises like this
really hard to listen to uh it's
terrible buzzing rattling sound that
spoils every single note
when you hear this out of your
instrument
it can be terrifying you can think
there's something terribly wrong inside
your your beautiful baby
the good news is that very often this
terrible buzzing noise can be fixed
instantly without taking your guitar to
the shop so let's learn how to fix a
buzzing guitar
so in my last video we learned all about
how to change the strings on a classical
guitar and when i was finished changing
those strings for the video i picked up
the guitar and i heard these terrible
sounds
now i've been playing plucked
instruments for a long time and i'm very
aware of the causes of these sounds and
it turns out that there are numerous
ways a acoustic guitar can buzz and by
the way this applies to
loots early guitars the orbos oods
mandolins most acoustic uh plucked
instruments but like i said earlier the
good news is that there's a lot of
really quick fixes here that will
instantly
solve the issue without you having to
spend money at a guitar repair shop
the first way is so easy to fix this
terrible sound that we're hearing that
sounds like there's something internally
broken in my instrument
is caused because i didn't clip the ends
of the strings
just the other day someone messaged me
on instagram and said help i don't know
what's going on my guitar it sounds
terrible they showed me a picture and
they had all these strings sticking out
like this and i said just trim those
strings and
the problem went away so on a nylon
string guitar you can just use a
fingernail clippers just find the really
long ends and clip them as close as you
can without disturbing the knot
so i have two strings that were touching
the top and making that really really
terrible sound
and now i predict we have no buzzing
[Music]
and it's gone another easy solution is
if you have
lots of strings long strings hanging out
the headstock that haven't yet been
trimmed
it's possible that they're touching one
of the other strings that are vibrating
and are causing the buzz so by trimming
the excess string you'll get rid of that
problem
i do like to coil them up in little
balls because
with more expensive strings you can
still salvage it but of course if it's
causing a buzz problem
just trim it off
[Music]
but if you've already trimmed the
strings at the bridge and you're still
getting a buzzing sound
well we have to look elsewhere let's
start by playing just your open strings
and maybe kind of heavy with a rest
stroke on the thumb
if those strings any of those strings
buzz then we have an issue that has to
be fixed but let's say you don't have
time to take your guitar to a repair
shop and you don't have a measuring tool
to check out your action here's a really
quick solution to help you in a pickle
let's say for example when you played
your open e string you got some sound
like this
if that's the case then we have to
address the problem at the nut
and the quick solution for this is to
grab a
thick piece of paper
not quite the thickness of a business
card but maybe thicker than your average
printer paper i'm going to use the
packaging paper from the aquila strings
i'm using because the paper is thicker
than your average
printer paper so we're going to take
kind of a long rectangle and then we're
going to fold it in half and what we're
going to do is we're going to put the
string in that little that little v
and now we have the string cradled
in this little piece of paper and now
what you can do is loosen
the e string down a bit so it's a bit
more
loose than usual
and now you're going to go towards the
nut with the string in the little cradle
and you're going to try to get into
the nut slot so underneath
the string and in between the nut slot
of the string so then once it's in there
you're going to then tune back the
string
[Music]
and now the paper has lifted the string
very slightly and maybe
you've gotten rid of
your buzz
if your buzz persists
you might have to get a thicker
piece of paper now the real trick here
is making sure the piece of paper uh
doesn't go on to the actual string it's
sitting inside the nut slot or a little
bit back in the nut slot if it's on the
string it'll mute it like this
that's no good we have to get the piece
of paper farther in the nut slot so
either grab it and then push it further
and see if you can get it
in the right place
that sounds good um or you can loosen
the string again and then see if you can
wiggle it around to find the sweet spot
i use this trick on a lot of my loots
and sometimes i have lots of pieces of
paper
in the in the nut slots now if you're
noticing that all of the open strings
are buzzing or that paper is not helping
you might need to do something more
radical
so one option that's a do-it-yourself
option would be actually to loosen all
the strings and take out the nut and
then put a piece of paper underneath a
shim so you can do that with a business
card which is like a millimeter thick
you just trace the size of the nut and
then you would lay that
down and then put the nut back down and
then put the strings on top and tighten
it back up thereby raising the entire
nut a millimeter
and seeing how it works you might have
to raise it two millimeters hopefully
not much more than that because if it
gets too high here it gets really really
hard to
fret the the notes perhaps a better
long-term option would be then to
definitely take it to a guitar repair
shop and have that make you
a brand new nut
[Music]
another really common source of buzzing
actually comes from the clothing or
jewelry that you're wearing
very often i get dressed up for a
concert and suddenly i'm wearing all
these buttons and a jacket with a button
on the sleeve and i suddenly hear this
buzzing sound that's very distracting
right before the concert
if you have a button that's accidentally
touching the guitar
on your wrist or jewelry or a necklace
that's touching it or buttons
those will vibrate with the instrument
and will cause terrible sounds so
prepare by dressing up before the
concert and getting used to it because
you might have to adjust the fabric roll
up your sleeves
wear a tie do something
to get any type of loose hard object
from buzzing on the instrument
[Music]
okay so what if the problem isn't with
the open strings here it's only when you
fret notes that you have buzz it's
likely that that problem might come from
the bridge side that could mean that
your the saddle which is that white
piece that goes into the bridge
is not high enough
it could also mean that your neck angle
uh is wrong but that's a bit more
complicated so let's hope it's just your
saddle height because again a
do-it-yourself at-home option would be
to just shim it
so again just loosen the strings
all the way down
every one of them
again this doesn't harm your instrument
at all just go all the way down take the
tension off with every string and then
once it's loose enough the white piece
the saddle will just slide right out
then
put the white piece
onto a business card trace it cut that
out put the business card
into the slot
then the saddle and then the strings on
top and tighten it back up you will have
raised
the
height of the saddle and thereby raising
the strings and this might take care of
your buzzing if it doesn't you could put
another business card on there so again
you can shim to make this happen
or in the end probably it's best to
eventually have a luthier or a guitar
repair shop make you a new saddle that's
at the right the right height
[Music]
do
[Music]
you